i want to give you a little
sort of chapter in the book about how
extreme the american right-wing movement
is getting there's this uh sort of like
on-campus right-wing group called
turning point usa charlie kirk is one of
the um sort of more publicly
known people associated with this group
turning point usa
they have now jumped fully into this
sort of conspiracy q anon alex jones
fray
to the point that at a recent event
called defeating the great reset the
great reset is a favorite
idea i guess we would call it of people
like alex jones and steve bannon and
those types
charlie kirk actually interviewed alex
jones this was at one point sort of like
cons i i never considered them this but
considered by the right a very
mainstream right-wing group just
indoctrinating college students into
basic conservative economics and this
type of thing
it is
completely over the hill
insane at this point in time and i'm
going to play for you a clip here of
charlie kirk making a really big deal of
i mean listen after all it's just alex
jones it's just a conspiracy theorist
this is the great thinker that turning
point usa
is bringing to its attendees it's it's
sad but also scary in that it shows how
extreme this movement has gotten a
special remote guest for you now
i only ask this since we're doing the
remote guest um while i'm while we're
talking i just want to make sure our
guest can hear
everything we're saying and all that so
i was told by everybody
it's not the president trump but it is
going to make you guys wait till you see
this all right wow
must be pretty good in fact this man is
more hated by the media than donald
trump and that says something okay
which is so
if you're going to talk about the great
reset right then you have to have which
by the way i don't know why you would
but someone who's the most banned man in
america alex jones joins us
[Applause]
how exciting we're now gonna get the
truth
[Music]
standing ovation to the guy who said
something about
gay frogs and that sandy hook was fake
[Applause]
so alex whoa alex welcome remotely i was
told by all the people like oh you can't
have alex at your event which makes me
just want to have alex even more
anything that people say is bad is
actually good that's fundamentally
conservatism sometimes
and i want to be reactionary
conservatism
sometimes things that people say are bad
are actually just bad
alex you wrote a book on the great reset
that's the great reset why did you write
the
book well i saw steve bannon yesterday
and he's absolutely right and i love the
you know the title yeah
um they are now including alex jones in
official
turning point usa events
here's what i hope you will glean from
this
these are considered the thinkers among
the right
these are considered the thinkers among
the right here's one more clip where
alex jones talks about cows biblically
let's let's zero in on the food thing
alex in particular they are fascinated
with getting rid of meat
talk more about that but also talk about
the other implications of getting rid of
meat testosterone levels maybe replacing
with this synthetic nonsense that bill
gates just happens to also be an
investor in by the way super crony
capitalist talk about the why they're so
incredibly focused on eradicating meat
from our planet what's going what's
going on with us yeah tell us well if
you go back to genesis anybody should go
read it written 3 000 plus years ago by
amazing jewish scribes
i'm so not anti-semitic that i'm going
to call the jewish scribes amazing
inspired by god
i mean in the first chapter they just
keep talking about cows and meat all day
long and saying that's the real symbol
of freedom now moses said later we're
not going to worship the golden calf
that's a dollar tree but they were
worshiping golden cow let's let's this
this guy is truly pathetic and i want to
tell you what the real scam is here
the real scam
is this entire movement pretending to
care about the bible we talked with ben
dixon about this in the last segment and
he says these people aren't even really
christian
um this was the moment
at which point it became clear
that the five six years that followed
were going to be republicans
pretending to care about the bible you
mentioned the bible you've been talking
about how it's your favorite book and
you said i think last night in iowa some
people are surprised that you say that
i'm wondering what one or two of your
most favored bible uh verses are i
wouldn't want to get into it because to
me that's very personal you know when i
talk about the bible it's very personal
so i don't want to get into real estate
i don't want to get into it
by the way
notice how articulate trump was even
just how much more articulate trump was
even just a few years ago a lot to you
that you think about her
the bible means a lot to me but i don't
want to get into specifics
even to cite a verse i don't want to do
that an old testament guy or a new
testament probably
equal i think it's just an incredible
are you a pancakes or a french toast guy
both are good but both are really good
the whole bible is an incredible i joke
very much so they always hold up the art
of the deal i say my second favorite
book of all time but
i just think the bible is just something
very special it's super special and
donald trump is not going to say any any
more about it these are
the exact type of panderers
that ben dixon was just warning about in
the last segment
who he is fighting against really scary
stuff
the only streaming service dedicated to
documentaries is curiosity stream our
longtime sponsor on curiositystream you
will find the best selection of
documentaries better than any other
platform they've got the newest and most
critically acclaimed titles i've been
watching curiositystream in my living
room i recently watched the six episode
series inside the mind of a con artist
i'm fascinated by scammers and cons and
how they get away with what they do
really great series that i can recommend
to you curiosity stream is always adding
new content they've got documentaries by
filmmakers we know and love but they
make it easy to find new independent
documentaries as well if you want to
absorb as much as you can curiosity
stream is for you if you want to retain
very little once you turn off the tv you
can also just relax with like a nature
documentary curiosity stream has those
too and with the special discount for my
audience you can get curiosity stream
for 15 bucks a year not not a month a
year that's under two bucks a month go
to
curiositystream.compacman and use the
code pacman the link is down below